[Musique]
et voilà en direct Alexis Corbière qui
s'installe bonjour Alexis Corbière et
merci
on est au mois de juillet
avec la presse régionale représentée par
Fabrice laissart Redon du groupe Evra
bonjour Fabrice merci d'être là on a
beaucoup de sujets à voir avec vous
évidemment Alexis Corbières et d'abord
cette notion de censure que vous avez
déposée la semaine dernière et qui sera
donc débattu cet après-midi à 16h dans
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée ce n'est pas
une motion de censure mais une motion de
posture ce n'est pas moi c'est Olivier
Véran qui dit ça est-ce qu'il n'a pas
raison vous l'avez déposé avant même le
début du discours d'Elisabeth borne
précisément ces sacs devraient écouter
levier Véran mais comme toujours lui il
attaque sans rentrer dans le fond il y a
deux manières d'aborder
le discours dit de méthode que fait
madame borne certes le contenu nous le
critiquons mais avant même qu'elle ait
fait son discours elle avait annoncé
qu'elle n'a pas le repas des députés à
faire en vote de confiance et nous qui
voulons je voulais déjà dit ici et ça a
été dit par tous mes amis repart le
montarisé la vie politique considérant
que pour la première fois certes le
président de la République a été élu
mais ses amis n'ont pas de majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale donc il va falloir
discuter et ça devient le nouveau lieu
de pouvoir
majorité Assemblée nationale y compris
le Sénat donc c'est c'est passionnant
parce qu'on on peut commencer à sortir
de cette culture de l'ultra
présidentialisation bon dans ce cadre là
une chef de gouvernement qui vient dans
l'Assemblée nationale et qui dit je vais
vous je vais parler mais quoi qu'il en
soit une fois que j'aurai terminé je ne
soumettrai rien en vote cela ne nous va
pas parce que c'est en quelque sorte
tordre le bras au député à la
représentation nationale donc ça déjà et
c'est une question la plus qu'on parle
méthode contre méthode jamais nous
n'accepterons que quiconque exerce le
pouvoir dans le pays avec pour seul
légitimité le fait qu'elle ait été
désignée par le Président de la
République le public est-ce que vous
allez pas lui donner la légitimité
puisque votre motion de censure se fait
une énorme surprise sera rejetée ça ne
passera pas est-ce que c'est pas vous
qui allez lui offrir cette légitimité
cet après-midi mais comment je suis
toujours surpris par ce type de question
c'est la moindre des choses de vérifier
qui est favorable ou qui n'est pas
favorable à ce qui est proposé en fait
je connaissez-vous un système
démocratique où vous avez une élection
qui désigne un président au mois d'avril
puis après qui désigne avec certes il a
pris du temps une chef de gouvernement
des élections ont lieu elle n'est pas
majoritaire mais elle reste en place et
tout continue comme avant et alors
qu'elle c'est tout de même singulier
dans la vie politique ça veut dire
quelque chose comment dirais-je les
Français qui nous regardent quand ils
votent il faut que ça ait du sens parce
que si culturellement idéologiquement on
habitude et français à quel que soit ce
que vous votez ça continuera comme avant
il y a un gouvernement il n'est pas
majoritaire dans les ions il continue
comme avant ce n'est pas bon vous venez
d'utiliser le mot système est-ce que
c'est le système qui vous pose problème
est-ce que vous êtes antisystème Alexis
il y a deux questions premièrement je
suis contre les institutions de la
Cinquième République je pense que comme
professeur d'histoire en 58 elle
naissent dans un moment très particulier
on vient de fêter les 60 ans
d'indépendance de l'Algérie qui est en
manque de crise politique ou un homme le
général de Gaulle auréolé de son rôle
durant la Seconde Guerre mondiale vient
dans un coup de force et modifie des
institutions bref vous connaissez notre
discours je suis pour passer en 6e
République pour rester fidèle à la
République parce que moi j'aime la
République mais la République qui
exprime la souveraineté populaire bon ça
donc je suis contre ce système après je
suis contre le système économique à
l'heure actuelle qui existe qu'on
appelle vulgairement le capitalisme vous
pouvez l'appeler comme vous voulez un
système qui vise aujourd'hui à de plus
en plus être dans un rapport de
prédation de toutes choses y compris de
la planète donc de ce point de vue là je
suis si vous voulez anti-système mais
s'il y a des gens qui aiment le monde
dans lequel ils sont c'est qu'il aime
moi j'adore le monde dans lequel on vit
du point de vue des êtres humains la
planète mais je trouve que ce système
économique abîme la planète et je pense
que quand on est républicain on peut pas
accepter les inégalités ça la pensée à
la base même d'une pensée insoumise de
gauche un peu là comme une dernière
question là-dessus parce que vous dites
le gouvernement n'a pas entendu le
message des Français Olivier Véran il
vous renvoie cet argument hier il dit
cette notion de censure c'est la
négation même du vote des Français qui
nous ont demandé de travailler dans le
compromis qu'est-ce que vous lui dites
que ça ne veut strictement rien dire
c'est du baratin typique de l'Aveyron
c'est quoi le compromis de quoi
parlons-nous je ne sais pas prenons les
dossiers sortons de l'hyperstructure
sémantique je suis contre la retraite 65
ans je suis contre ce qu'a dit Madame
borne qu'il faut la dire à la tribune de
l'Assemblée nationale j'ai d'ailleurs
protesté certains ont dit ah Corbières à
crier mais je n'accepterai pas au
gouvernement je ne soutiendrai pas un
grand qui dit qu'il faut travailler plus
longtemps quand il y a tant d'inégalités
quand il y a tant de gens qui sont
notamment parmi des ouvriers après 62
ans qui sont déjà décédés au travail le
travail use et nous avons la capacité au
contient de d'imaginer un système de
retraite qui revient à 60 ans
il y a des des mesures sur lesquelles
vous pourriez travailler vous pourriez
trouver un compromis avec le
gouvernement alors comme toujours il y a
le clin d'oeil qui est une opération de
communication mais je veux aller dans
votre sens elle dit faut il faut aller
vers un EDF 100% public là on va
réfléchir elle l'annonce c'est quand
même singulier y compris là aussi que je
t'appelle singulier c'est que moi
j'avais des collègues de en marche à
côté ils l'ont découvert aussi quand
elle l'a dit c'est-à-dire qu'en sur un
sujet aussi important aussi stratégique
qui mériterait qu'on travaille de quoi
parlons-nous est-ce que c'est
nationalisation parce que là on rentre
des jeux subtil on m'a dit non mais elle
a pas dit nationalisation elle a dit
100% alors on va voir et puis y compris
il y a des dettes qui ont été accumulées
37 milliards de dettes je crois
aujourd'hui parodie a fait ce qu'il
s'agit dans quelques sortes de
nationaliser les dettes et après de
privatiser les profits
ine la mission d'information vous
soutenez ça bah moi je suis pour qu'on
prenne initiative comme toujours comme
on connaît des accords avec Madame Le
Pen mais elle a raison de ce point de
vue là de dire attendez on veut voir la
vérité de la marchandise parce qu'on a
bien compris je l'ai vu dans le visage
d'un homme la première ministre quand
elle a dit ça elle s'est tourné vers la
gauche avec un sourire du genre je vous
ai bien eu mais pardon acceptez l'idée
que nous aussi nous ne soyons pas des
gogos qui se font attraper uniquement
parce qu'on nous fait une astuce
j'aimerais savoir parce que je les
connais je connais madame borne il
suffit pas qu'il nous disent des choses
pour qu'il nous attend nous tombions
sous le charme de ce qui est dit je veux
rentrer dans le détail soyons concrets
et là on va en parler sans doute une
inflation jamais vu plus de 5%
électrique augmente comment on répond à
ça c'est ça parce que sur ce texte
pouvoir d'achat ça c'est une vraie
préoccupation des Français c'est une
inquiétude ça serait examiné la semaine
prochaine à l'Assemblée est-ce que là
vous êtes prêt encore une fois des
compromis sur ce texte est-ce qu'il y a
des mesures que vous pourriez monter sur
lesquels vous pourriez travailler avec
le gouvernement ne commencez pas la
discussion de ce que je suis prêt à
décompris je suis pour voter tout ce qui
est favorable aux Français
alors justement alors quoi alors quoi
alors ce texte parlons-en est-ce que les
son il s'agit dans le meilleur des cas
ces trois et demi pour cent
d'augmentation alors que l'inflation est
à 5% nous nous proposons 10% notamment
sur notamment sur les fonctionnaires par
exemple est-ce qu'on peut accepter
l'idée à l'heure où les fois les loyers
flammes que le gouvernement accepte
l'idée d'une augmentation encore des
loyers successivement à celles qui ont
déjà eu lieu qui montrait jusqu'à 3h30
moi je suis pour qu'on arrête là d'ores
et déjà ils comprennent des mesures
d'urgence par exemple sur ce point-là et
ainsi de suite finalement quand on fait
le bilan sans un je vais à l'essentiel
c'est souvent des choses qui étaient
déjà prévues début 2023 qui sont
légèrement anticipés du point de vue la
revolisation notamment je crois de
certains minima sociaux donc pour dire
les choses simplement ça vaut pas
tripette d'accord beaucoup de ces
mesures sont dérisoires et 20 mic
provisoires et je dirais illusoire à
l'arrivée les autour de ce triptyque moi
je suis pour avancer si on peut y
arriver et nous allons chercher à créer
des majorités au sein de l'Assemblée
nationale mais comment dirais-je sur des
choses qui changent la vie vraiment pas
des choses qui ne rattrapent même pas
parce que avant l'inflation ça allait
mal hein je sais pas si Madame board
s'en souvient on va s'en souvenir
mouvement des gilets jaunes des
protestations sociales là ce qui est
clair c'est que le texte qui nous est
proposé ne permet même pas de faire face
à l'inflation
un truc qui pour faire des clins d'oeil
parce que j'aime ça la première chose
que j'avais fait il y a 5 ans en
arrivant à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
protester contre la baisse des appels à
tel point que j'avais sorti des boîtes
de concert dans l'hémicycle et j'avais
reçu de la part du président un blâme
donc tact et bien figurez-vous que là
désormais les mêmes qui ont baissé les
appels proposent de légèrement les
relever c'est à dire c'est comme le
travail de Pénélope qui refait le jour
ce qu'elle a défait la nuit est-ce bien
sérieux à l'heure ou par exemple on
augmente telle là aussi pour taquiner la
baisse des appels avait été conseillé
par un cabinet conseil qui s'appelait
mckinsee qu'on avait payé gracieux
généreusement bref voyez tout ça n'est
pas cohérent moi je me ferais pas avoir
s'il y a des petits points qui changent
la vie qui améliorent les gens certes
mais tout ça n'est pas à la hauteur
c'est une opération de communication
gouvernante de 20 milliards par rapport
au plan initial qui était adopté la
semaine mais d'un autre côté il y a les
voyants qui sont au rouge sur la dette
aussi la quadrature du cercle non mais
attendez pas je crois que c'est Olivier
fort qui qui s'est levé que qui se lever
qu'avec l'inflation c'est près de 57
milliards de recettes supplémentaires
que notamment avec la TVA le
gouvernement vous dites va renverser 20
milliards donc les chiffres ne sont pas
à la hauteur de la situation puisse
venir il s'agit des tracés exactement à
qui profitent parce qu'on a vu souvent
que beaucoup d'aides qui sont accordées
par ce gouvernement profitent à
certaines personnes qui concentrent les
richesses comme on l'a jamais vu on est
aujourd'hui une situation où les plus
fortunés ont voulu dernièrement en
période de crise leur fortune augmenter
236 milliards pour les principales
fortunes françaises donc ce que je veux
dire c'est que cibler les plus modestes
le chèque à la rentrée ciblera les plus
les foyers 9 millions de foyers les plus
modestes là Elisabeth borne elle a dit
rencontrer économique d'Aix-en-Provence
que le bouclier tarifaire pourrait être
remplacé par des aides pour les foyers
les plus modestes est-ce que ça c'est
une par exemple non mais tout ça c'est
par exemple est-ce qu'il est normal
parce qu'il faut entendre le détail si
par exemple sur le prix du carburant
c'est une question qui prend tout le
monde à la gorge à tel point que la
moindre véhicule aussi petit soit-il
vous mettez 100 euros quasiment à la
pompe qui est devenu fou bon est-ce que
c'est et en même temps le groupe Total
pour parler de lui pardon c'est le plus
emblématique vient de faire 16 milliards
de de profits du jamais vu est-ce que
c'est à l'argent public de donner des
petites aides pour compenser des
accumulations
pour le privé il y a une logique quand
on est républicain moi je m'excuse mais
l'argent public ne sert pas à compenser
des bénéfices colossaux qui vont dans
les poches des privés
de faire des efforts
ça c'est intéressant parce qu'avec Bruno
Le Maire qui est vraiment l'homme sans
doute le plus structuré du gouvernement
et je veux dire donc il faut écouter sa
parole que je prends toujours au sérieux
moi j'avais eu un débat j'ai l'esprit
d'escalier pardon mais sur la question
des frais bancaires avec Bruno Le Maire
dans l'hémissi coup j'étais pour
plafonner les frais bancaires ça coûte
il y a 7 milliards d'euros que les
français payent pour des frais bancaires
tout est petites pénalités qui prennent
quand on fait un chèque etc Bruno Le
Maire m'avait dit Monsieur Corbières
vous avez parfaitement raison mais votre
loi j'ai un soutiendrai pas je préfère
inciter les banques à baisser les frais
bancaires ça n'a rien produit les frais
bancaires quand tu dois augmenter là
c'est la même idée les incitations on
aimerait que Madame bande qui dit aussi
aux entreprises qu'il faudrait augmenter
les salaires qui ou la prime que
certains entreprises peuvent verser à
des salles tout ça ne produit rien en
vérité ne significatif il faut légiférer
c'est pas que je suis un torque madame
législatif mais parce qu'au bout d'un
moment l'incitation il faudrait que ne
produit rien si ce n'est évidemment dans
une période des effets d'aubaine aussi
de certaines entreprises qui
défiscalisent des choses qui étaient
prévues d'augmentation de salaire qui
font moins de recettes à l'état ou alors
que je le répète souvent de la part de
groupe qui ne font pas grand chose donc
je crois que l'heure est à l'action
concrète y compris à des rapports de
force parce que en même temps que les
Français sont en situation difficile je
répète il y a des gens qui accumulent
des richesses il y a des profiteurs de
crises des profiteurs de guerre pour
reprendre la terminologie du prénom de
la République quand ils nous sommes en
guerre à l'occasion du covid j'observe
quand même pendant cette période où les
Français on fait beaucoup d'efforts
certains ont profité pour accumuler des
richesses moi je suis partagé sur
l'inflation merci de le rappeler
c'est-à-dire que dans ce cadre là tout
de même tout son va faire nos courses au
supermarché ou ailleurs bref et les prix
deviennent fous et on entend une musique
signification avec des personnalités je
vais pas les citer qui disent qu'il y a
des effets spéculatifs que ces prix que
augmente ne sont pas uniquement dus y
compris Michel est dans Leclerc vous
l'avez cité qui n'est pas comment
dirais-je un perdre de l'année non plus
mais qui disait chose qui connaît son
sujet et qui dit là il y a des effets
spéculatifs ben moi je suis pour que
nous nous les députés nous allions au
bout et au fond de cette discussion donc
cette enquête en auditionnant qui tous
les acteurs a commencé par tous les
acteurs de la grande consommation pour
voir un peu puis il va falloir remonter
un peu la filière comment ça se fait
qu'aujourd'hui quand un fruit de les
produits par un agriculteur que il nous
coûte 1 €, il y en a que 8 centimes qui
va à lui qui sont les différents
intermédiaires comment ça se fait que ça
coûte si cher qui c'est qui prend des
marches quelles sont ses effets spé
négatif etc on va regarder un peu ce
dossier puis par ailleurs aussi des
associations pardon de consommateurs en
fait toute une série d'acteurs de ce
secteur on va voir et on va peut-être
découvrir certains scandales je ne sais
pas on va je pensais à un autre sujet
qui arrive là sur la place comment ça se
fait que peut-être des intérêts privés
aujourd'hui sont aujourd'hui défendus
peut-être par certains acteurs
politiques on va voir puisque vous
parlez des ubersheim plusieurs médias
dans le dont le monde dans le journal
ont révélé un pacte secret entre la
société uber et Emmanuel Macron quand il
était ministre de l'Économie entre 2014
et 2016 certaines pratiques qui étaient
destinées à aider uber à consolider ces
positions en France sont pointées du
doigt qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ces
révélations que c'est très grave c'est
très grave
d'usage en dit si la presse dit vrai
mais là on va considérer quand même que
c'est la crème de la crème de la presse
investigation donc c'est très grave
l'idée que en fait monsieur Macron a
dans un accord ce pacte secret avec une
entreprise dérégulée la réglementation
notamment en matière en matière de taxi
est intervenue
essayer de modifier notamment une
décision d'un préfet même si c'était je
pense que ce qui s'est passé à Marseille
monsieur Nunès dit que c'est pas le cas
mais enfin il y a une chronologie que
nous raconte la presse qui est
troublante c'était un préfet prend une
mesure qui est défavorable à
l'installation du verre Hubert saisi
monsieur Macron qui dit je vais m'en
occupé puis quelques jours après le
préfet modifier des choses enfin bon on
prend tous les éléments qui sont
annoncés c'est très grave voilà écoutez
moi j'ai une certaine idée de la
République qui fait que le président ou
celui qui va être président ne peut pas
être en lobbyiste au service d'intérêt
privé et d'une entreprise
nord-américaine qui parieur a plus que
des délicatess avec soit les États-Unis
avec se dire qu'il cherche à contourner
chaque fois les réglementations qui même
ne les respecte pas c'est pas possible
et là il y a quelque chose de très fort
alors quelles leçons on tient
d’apprendre hier soir sans aucun doute
évidemment poser la question là dans les
journées je pense notamment à l'occasion
là ce qu'on peut s'adresser au
gouvernement une commission d'enquête
également il faut voir comment
on va en discuter avec nos amis pourquoi
pas faire quelque chose de l'ensemble
des composantes de la nupaise pour dire
il faut urgemment que nous puissions
faire toute la clarté là-dessus et en
tirer les conséquences je pense c'est
une condition indispensable
je vous avais déjà celle sur sur
l'inflation
d'enquête après il y a des droits de
tirage selon les groupes mais on peut
discuter avec nos amis de voir comment
on peut comme une paire de triage
ça peut bousculer peut-être en
calendrier qu'on avait prévu ça
nécessite une discussion politique pour
ne pas le banaliser vous comprenez ce
que je suis en train de dire
qu'elle est reprise par d'autres à ce
stade je suis Emmanuel Macron doit
s'expliquer pour vous ah bah c'est la
moindre des choses parce que là vous
dites vous allez poser la question
question gouvernement si j'ai bien
compris donc ça évidemment ce sera le
gouvernement qui vous répondra est-ce
que vous dites Emmanuel Macron en
personne doit s'expliquer moi je pense
que oui mais s'il le fait pas on est
dans l'irresponsabilité présidentielle
de la 5e République dont on parlait tout
à l'heure en gros je suis élu je fais ce
que je veux et je non écoutez là on
touche quand même quelque chose de dur
je pense notamment au chauffeur de taxi
toute cette profession qui a été mis en
concurrence y compris au chauffeur
d'Hubert bien souvent parce qu'il y en a
beaucoup soi-disant que ça donnait du
travail il faut voir la grande précarité
dans laquelle ça a mis des gens la
déréglementation de beaucoup de choses
enfin moi je n'accepte pas l'idée que la
France doit être le terrain de jeu de
ces grands groupes privés on a bien
compris que vous les portez pas dans
votre coeur
Hubert une société comme ça là vous
pensez qu'elle peut quitter le français
mais moi je ne suis pas pour ces
systèmes d'auto-entrepreneurs de gens
ultra précarisés qui travaillent pendant
des heures je pense qu'il faut de la
réglementation y compris sur cette
profession et le modèle uber pour faire
pour faire simple et ton modèle d'ultra
précarité
d'absence de protection en vérité des
salariés qui ne produire un de bon voilà
donc effectivement je ne suis pas pour
le modèle uber je sais pas pour uberiser
la société pour le dire non je ne suis
pas pour cuber se développe et
s'installe dans le pays je suis pour la
réglementation des règles équitables en
tout des droits de protection pour les
salariés des systèmes de cotisation etc
ouais en fait quand on voit même pardon
je suis un peu à côté de la cible parce
que je repense l'article que j'ai dû
hier soir que initialement il y avait
250 heures prévues de formation pour
être chauffeur VTC uber et que Monsieur
Macron est intervenu pour qu'il n'y ait
plus que 7 heures de formation c'est de
la dégradation y compris pour le client
pour tout le monde enfin je veux dire
moi j'accepte pas l'idée que dans notre
société maintenant on dit allez en
quelques heures vous êtes formés basta
va travailler
un sujet sur lequel vous la France
insoumise souhaite se pencher sont les
cabinets de conseils Éric Coquerel soit
une mission d'information sur les
cabinets de conseils alors là on
comprend pas parce que les sénateurs ont
fait un travail sur ce sujet avec une
magnifique travail avec une proposition
de loi à la clé du coup demandez une
mission d'information c'est pas un peu
une forme de mépris pour le travail du
Sénat
en plus il avait fait en communiqué
expliquant déjà en seulement le travail
qui a été fait notamment Parian assassy
et j'oublie le nom de du Colette et
Monsieur Bazin voilà qui a été qui a
posé un sujet et communiste
du travail qui a été fait parce que
beaucoup de pistes ont été ouvertes par
la commission sénatoriale et que la
commission de l'Assemblée nationale
pourrait continuer à affiner
voilà bah lui maintenant il a c'est à sa
main si je puis dire et ne pas reprendre
la proposition de loi du Sénat puisque
il y a un texte législatif qui est parce
que je crois qu'il y a des sujets de
vérification qui devaient être fait sur
le des bilans depuis le travail qui a
été fait au Sénat c'est dans cet état
d'esprit que les choses se sont faites
n'ont pas pour s'opposer au contraire
mais pour continuer ce travail qui a été
fait et pour considérer aussi que
l'Assemblée nationale comment dirais-je
doit pas être seulement observateur
admiratif de ce que fait le Sénat mais
aussi qu'on peut prendre en charge de
telles dossier c'est pas c'est pas
s'opposé que de continuer ce travail qui
a ouvert beaucoup de questions donc je
crois que c'est non non non
pardon j'ai une question sur le travail
vous avez vu pénurie de main d'oeuvre
sur tous les fronts on est de
l'hôtellerie mais pas seulement à
l'heure qu'il est beaucoup beaucoup de
secteurs sont en manque de main d'oeuvre
notamment de la jeune main d'oeuvre
comment vous l'expliquez comment on sort
de ça ben vous je vais vous dire je l'ai
vécu très concrètement avec certains de
mes enfants les rémunérations que sont
proposées parfois dans des endroits où
pour le transport c'est extrêmement
compliqué sur des horaires font des
horaires très compliqué quand des jeunes
n'ont pas de moyens de transport qui
font que ça ne favorise pas aussi le
fait que tous ces emplois soient soit
pourvu le payer vous dites c'est mal
payé précariser mal payés sur des
horaires compliqués etc bon donc ça crée
pas les conditions aussi d'une grande
émulation donc faut rentrer dans le
détail le soi-disant de discours comme
quoi il y a du boulot il suffit d'aller
le chercher regardons concrètement où
est-ce que et des conditions de
rémunération de ces boulots voilà après
faut là où ça aide dans la restauration
je veux pas faire un jour à ce beau
métier que de considérer souvent que les
conditions de travail les horaires vont
même au-delà de ce qui est écrit sur une
route ou la ou la fiche de poste donc la
nouveauté c'est qu'il n'y a pas que
l'hôtellerie restauration qui touchait
pas ce manque de main d'oeuvre oui oui
bah écoutez faut voir faut rentrer dans
le détail vous savez beaucoup de ces
soi-disant en point non pourvu il y a
des enquêtes qui ont été montrées sont
en vérité des fiches de poste qui sont
tombées en désuétude sont en vérité des
fiches de poste qui sont forts mal
rédigées sont en réalité des fiches de
poste qui parlent leur rémunération crée
des conditions quasi impossibles de
pouvoir y répondre donc là je veux dire
moi je veux bien qu'on discute sur la
formation aussi des salariés c'est très
important renforcer la formation de
manière générale la formation
professionnelle en particulier mais les
employeurs aussi doivent s'interroger de
pourquoi bien souvent leur emploi ne
sont pas pourvus pour quelles raisons
moi je je pense à une grande plateforme
d'un aéroport de la région parisienne
qui cherche du monde sans parler enfin
avec des responsables mais c'est il faut
commencer à 5h du matin avec une
rémunération très basse si vous n'avez
pas de moyens de transport automobile
vous ne pouvez quasiment pas y aller à
l'arrivée il s'étonne qu'il trouve pas
du monde donc faut peut-être
s'interroger sur comment on crée les
conditions que les gens aller travailler
sans quasiment à l'arrivée perdre de
l'argent ou être à quelques centaines
d'euros un dernier mot sur cette
entretien qui a
accordé coupable d'un être d'un acte
grave par la justice pardon quel que
soit sa condition présent sur le
territoire national qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez c'est de l'assurance chair de
communication la loi doit s'appliquer
moi je suis pas pour que monsieur
Darmanin il fait là il fait des œufs yad
un électorat d'extrême droite faut
rentrer dans le détail chaque personne
le cas doit être examiné par la justice
je ne sais pas de quoi on parle de qui
on parle il y a des gens qui sont en
danger dans leur pays d'origine et quel
que soit ce qu'on en pense et bien avec
vous dans cet entretien il vous met sur
le même plan que le rassemblement
national
mercredi à l'Assemblée valait dans
l'outrance au lieu de Marine Le Pen
mais vous savez monsieur Darmanin je
pense qu'il a aujourd'hui un rôle de de
rabatteur dans le dispositif galantal je
sais pas si c'est très opérant moi
j'observe qu'il était celui à l'occasion
d'un débat face à Marine Le Pen où il
avait trouvé trop molle sur les
questions d'immigration il essaie de
prendre cette posture tout ça n'est pas
sérieux mais pour parler par exemple de
du discours de mon ami m'a-t-il panot il
faut qu'ils acceptent l'idée que nous
sommes une opposition extrêmement
déterminée et extrêmement fâché pour
dire les choses en termes politiques
vis-à-vis de ce que fait ce gouvernement
donc c'est beau messieurs qui pensent
qu'ils sont le soleil autour duquel
toutes les planètes doivent tourner que
ils sont vraiment ce qui se fait de
mieux doivent comprendre qu'il s'est
passé un événement considérable qui les
élections législatives dans lequel le
parti maintenant
l'Amicale de Monsieur Darmanin les amis
du Président je sais pas comment
l'appelait ensemble horizon renaissant
fait tout ça n'est pas majoritaire à
l'Assemblée nationale donc
ils vous disent la même chose ils vous
disent que vous aussi il faut que vous
compreniez que vous il y a eu des les
gens que vous n'avez pas gagné les
élections
après la différence avec moi je sais pas
si on les remarqué c'est un petit détail
je ne suis pas ministre lui il est
ministre avant les élections battu dans
les élections il reste bon chacun
appréciera
oui moi aussi d'accord et alors
non mais je veux dire
monsieur Darmanin le fait que c'est la
même équipe ou qui continue Monsieur le
Maire Monsieur Darmanin bon on prend les
mêmes on recommence moi ce que je veux
dire c'est faisons attention parce que
si les Français ont le sentiment déjà
qui a énormément d'abstention que on
vote et après ça n'a aucune conséquence
ni les hommes ou les femmes ne changent
ni la politique ne change bon alors
après monsieur Darmanin essaie d'exister
moi je le laisse assez turpitude mais
comment dirais-je entre les deux tours
quand il s'agissait pour Monsieur Macron
d'être face à Madame Le Pen le thon
était plus suave nous concernant et puis
là maintenant on renvoie tout le monde
de ado bon chacun appréciera le
caractère cynique à tout ça mais on
discutera après sur les dossiers points
par point et vous allez voir qu'on va se
faire entendre et on va être utile
merci merci beaucoup Alexis Corbières
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin et à
bientôt merci Fabrice
[Musique]